unidos contra la dictadura con esta y
otras consignas miles de franceses
protestaron en varias ciudades del país
contra el pase sanitario una medida que
consideran vulnera sus derechos estas
diez islas y toalla divide a los
ciudadanos a la sociedad también estamos
aquí para protestar contra la obligación
de ser vacunados por ejemplo yo estoy
vacunado pero rechazo forzar a la gente
a que se bajó niños con con luke con
ulises o hasta recibir en principio el
certificado se usaría únicamente para
eventos de más de 1.000 asistentes y en
discotecas posteriormente fue puesto en
cines teatros y espectáculos culturales
y deportivos con más de 50 personas por
último la asamblea nacional lo aprobó
para bares restaurantes y transporte
público que en la norma también se
establece la obligatoriedad de la
vacunación para el personal sanitario
sólo falta la luz verde del senado para
que entre en vigencia
creo que la vacunación sistemática es
una medida demasiado extrema y riesgosa
estoy indignada por esta extensión
incluso por los menores creo que no
tienen nada que ganar y se toman muchos
riesgos por salvar a los mayores
en australia los ciudadanos inundaron
las calles de sydney ante las estrictas
medidas implementadas y porque pese a
ellas los casos continúan en aumento
esa ciudad la más poblada del país se
encuentra confinadas del 27 de junio y
el viernes las autoridades indicaron que
algunas restricciones por el virus
podrían extenderse hasta octubre
la concentración a la que muchos no
asistieron sin tapabocas no contaba con
el permiso de las autoridades y un grupo
de manifestantes se enfrentó a la
policía por lo que se registraron
numerosas detenciones